I'm going to take your house away unless you dance in a circle
and call yourself a little piggy. Say, I'm a little piggy and
dance in a circle and then I won't take your house away, you
rancid.
But I fully deny will always stand on business denying the Skulla.
Okay, the Skullaost is not real. It is a hallucination. It is
political propaganda. It never happened. It doesn't I don't care.
Hutch, you're spiraling. Hutch, you're having a mental breakdown.
Hutch, wake up. Wake up. Hutch, wake up. [laughter]
>> I think I said we're going to go and do the loner box
stuff, didn't I? God, I was asked to do this content. Okay, I
do this content under duress. Not
Not literally. Apparently, Lonerbox reviewed the Huscogging
>> the Husco. Okay. Husco Hutch Piscoco.
I just blend words now. The Hutch Piscoco debate from Lib and
Learn. Lonerbox did like a little review on it. Lonerbox breaks
down the morality behind Ethan suing Casey Trron.
Okay, this is this is uh gonna be kind of rough. I think we'll
see. I just people try to defend Ethan because they say he can
sue whoever he wants. He can pick his targets however he wants.
And if he wants to sue people because they said because they
said they were going to steal views maliciously, then that's
his right. question of course operative question here being well
but he registered the copyright before publishing the video.
So how in the world when he was planning to sue people when he's
setting his trap so that he could sue people how in the world
could he have assumed that they go hey we're going to steal this
intentionally.
So, anybody who claims this is preemptively and automatically
a total.
But hey, who am I to say that lonerbox will do that? I don't
know that he'll do that. I really hope he doesn't do that because
it's really [__] stupid when people do that, but
they continue to do it over and over and over again. They never
said that before. I don't I don't think they said it before.
I'm just I'm just saying it's like it's very it's like oh man
please don't I just I think he won't say I think there's other
things you could say
right I think there's just other things you could say but if
you defend it on the lines of
well you could sue whoever you want and that's okay and like
and you could choose whatever reason you want picked this reason
but he didn't pick that reason he just wanted to sue these people
right
yeah he had no idea they would say that when he decided he wanted
to sue people that's just that's just how it is, man. Okay, so
anyway, that's like a very silly argument to make, but I guess
you could say that after
I don't even know what you'd say, actually, cuz you can defend
at most you could maybe slightly defend the Casey Tron lawsuit,
but it's like it's still disgusting, but like Casey Tron's just
such a rampid offender that like, okay, whatever.
But the other ones are Yeah. Casey who ser sincerely believes
even when I was playing Warcraft and just having videos on in
the background and not pausing that often. Even that was like
way above and beyond anything Casey Drum is doing. She just literally
she leaves videos on >> Peterson, but I did have breakfast,
but I did >> Oh, it's on his back. >> Breakfast.
I'm g we're trying to get at to what we care about, right? So,
the reason why I'm isolating this and giving >> I don't
understand what Pisco wants from this. Um,
>> Pisco is he's correct in in pointing out that when Ethan
said that this was to protect copyright or to set precedent that
it has to be malicious intent otherwise like that doesn't really
make any sense to me because obviously you don't need any malicious
intent to sue people. Uh, it makes sense in a moral way, like
as a moral argument, it's okay to say that. >> Oh, that
is actually probably true for most video games that you could
actually just get sued at any point in time. >> Yeah, I
think in in this social circle, it's probably okay to have a
standard that someone is maliciously talking >> Hold on,
that would be really funny. What if a video game developer just
sued like one big streamer cuz the big streamer was like you
to the video game developer.
Like what if what if they like they that one streamer but everybody
else they let through just the one streamer they're like actually
you would we be like oh you can sue whoever you want.
It's like so
gay. It's so unbelievably gay. The creatis change case change
your opinion at all. No cuz like the transformativity is not
even remotely comparable. The cretosis stuff is two different
streams for one tiny video over like 14 hours over two days.
It's like totally different in terms of transformation. I think
yeah, I don't think it's the same. But >> in in this social
circle, it's probably okay to have a standard if someone is maliciously
talking about stealing content or
>> it's happened. It just got settled.
Wait, what's happened? Sorry.
What are you talking about? Heavenly Zar, you said it's happened.
It just got settled. a big video game developer let 99.9% of
people stream their content and then just decided to sue one
only like like set a precedent like I'm telling you like they
stream tournaments and and like Counter-Strike or something like
with Counter-Strike or some [__] That's what I'm
talking about. Like like everybody does this as a matter of like
it's just standard standard practice and then they just just
decide to flip it for one person because they can. That would
be crazy to me >> from depriving you of views like intentionally
then it's you should probably have less sympathy for them when
they do it. Um,
especially with Casey Drawn because she literally is a market
replacement machine. She's like a serial market replacement machine.
Um, the thing that's bugging me about it though is like you can
hold Ethan to those standards and you can correct him on it,
but at the end of the day when you look at the the side that
he's like up against like that group like the Casey Draw and
Denons, all that, it's like >> it's like you're >> just
don't don't do Skulls CPS sword. Don't do it. Don't do it. Don't
do it. Um actually everything this group is one entity and we
it's a RICO case and basically everything bad empanada's done
is chargeable in all of them. I don't please don't is it's like
you're watch
out a moral or ethical position on this
on what
I can I can tell you just from not being a what Pisco's moral
and ethical position is. Um, those things are really bad. But
Ethan, without any without any
reasonable suspicion, cannot blame the bad things that have happened
to him on individuals and punish individuals for what an amorphous
group that he defines does. He can't just say, "This is the group
as I see them, and now I'm going to punish individuals from that
group with no proof that they actually participated in any of
the actions that I am actually upset about."
You can't you can't do that. I'm just saying bad empodotic because
somebody did it and he's the biggest baddest one. And that's
what I'm saying.
>> What are we defending? I'm saying that if you say that
because Ethan got skulls sent to his house, Caseyron deserves
to be to be sued or that like I have to blame Caseyron for this
because of or blame Casey Tron for CPS,
right? Pisco has said he's against it morally. Against what morally?
against call well everybody's against calling CPS like pretty
much like you shouldn't I don't think you should call CPS on
pretty much no evidence it's not no evidence literally it's just
very little evidence I'm just saying I don't like the idea listen
the collective guilt thing is very very very silly to me I'm
not a fan >> watching two groups fighting okay you're watching
two >> collective guilt collective punishment always silly
I mean he said Ethan was wrong oh well Ethan is in the wrong
but I'm saying that what what they're trying to argue is Lonerbox
is saying what about the other side though. Like what seems weird
to me is Pisco is not criticizing the other side of this
and it's like well I think he would criticize the other side
of this. I think he just doesn't think every single person on
the other side should be blamed for actions of like one or two
individual fringe agents,
right? Equally. And like, well, this guy with like I guarantee
you there are a whole bunch of people who see Case Trunk getting
sued and they're like, well, she helped call CPS and Ethan and
so she deserves whatever happens to her. And it's like, that's
obviously insane. In any other situation,
it's obviously
but just because you hate this rancid
You're like, "Oh, I'm going to come up with whatever justification
I want." Which is like goofy in my opinion. >> Two countries
fighting and one side is just firing chemical weapons
all over the shop.
>> Uh [sighs]
chemical weapons of the skull variety. Okay. And then the other
side gets a little bit
and drops like a tactical nuke on like one part of their installation
and you're like and then the only thing you're talking about
is like the tactical nuke that's being used. Yeah. >> Wait,
who did they hit other than Ethan? Who did they target other
than Ethan? Like what who did they what who did they target other
than Ethan?
I mean I I'm afraid you kind of did just support the collective
punishment thing.
But you're saying like chemical weapons, but there's only one
thing. They're hitting like the same installation over and over
again. The same like one or two people over and over again. Maybe
you could say like the crew of the H3 podcast, but it's like
nobody who's
I don't know. U maybe if you go that far then you could say Caseyron
isn't unrelated. But I don't think it's like the same. I don't
think any of those people have gotten anything that bad. I think
every I think
I'm going to get like blown up for this.
I don't know that,
you know, once you get six months out from October 7th, I don't
know that I see anybody as like this super bad guy in this. I
feel like there's a lot of people going back and forth to be
honest with you. Pisco thinks Ethan lied about his motivations
for suing. I am aware Ethan clearly lied about his motivations
for suing. I'm just trying to engage back and forth with uh what
do you call it? letter boxes hypothetical here cuz like I can
understand how people you know who are engaging this online this
online campaign back and forth and they're just using rhetoric
and then other people on their side do something crazy and they
don't really want to disavow it like I understand how that ends
up with um
with you know people dehumanizing each other and authorizing
just about anything. It's just about what you do personally,
right? In my opinion, you have to break it down to what people
do personally because if you do, oh, the whole group is guilty
for their worst people, then
I don't know, it gets pretty.
And unfortunately, Ethan is doing all of the stuff, all of his
rhetoric himself, and then other people are like individually
responsible for what they say. I just don't know what Caseyron
has done specifically
that makes it okay. So, I understand how everybody can go, well,
the side of Caseyron has done bad things, but what has Caseyron
done? Has anyone actually pointed out specific bad actions that
Casey Well, I I've pointed this out a lot, Tequila Sunset, that
when I ask people what Casey Tron did that was bad, it's like
basically nothing. And I can say I I don't like copyright infringement
generally, but I don't know what people broadly say Casey Tron
did that even made it so the skulls happened or CPS happened.
I actually don't know. I literally don't know. >> Yeah,
that's that's kind of the issue >> is like blaming all
for Israel. Yeah, it would be like that. Yeah, I I think the
uh behavior of the other side is like kind of the fact that they
just like there's nothing that holds them to account. Like it
doesn't matter how wrong they can be. It doesn't matter
>> Okay. Who are you holding to account and for what?
>> It's people have to be vague every time they talk about
it, which is weird. Um no, this isn't the case, Wendy. I guarantee
you she said she definitely said vile. I'm almost positive she
said something bad. Just nothing that would make it like her
deserving of getting sued this way. like the specific way she
did, right? >> Like moral their actions can be or how much
you can call it out. Like it doesn't affect them in the slightest.
Like they have no they're completely immune to all this. So at
the end of the day, people are going to use something. And I
guess Ethan used the copyright >> Well, nothing worked
so far. So I guess, you know, whatever they do now is fine. He
just yada yada yada a lot of stuff there in between like
in between normal strikes and then a tactical nuke. He just like
yada yada yada the whole in
Like did they try calling Caseyron fat? Like a fat disgusting
piece of [__] a couple times. Seems to work pretty
well for Asminold.
Asminold seems to be living his best life just being like Caseron,
you're a fat [__] You fat [__]
Like I'm I'm pretty sure I'm fine with Ethan doing that if he
wants to. I heard Casey Trump was smoking out of a skull bong
and drinking crystal skull vodka to celebrate the sending of
the skulls.
Well, you never know. Whoa.
example with Tim Pool is because it's your claim that you don't
give a [__] about the motivations, the rationale.
And so I'm trying to isolate that factor to show actually maybe
if this was against you or a person that you didn't quite like
suing, maybe actually you would care about the motivation and
whether they're misrepresenting it. But it feels like you're
you're fighting the >> but I would never do something as
stupid as tell my audience, hey [laughter] guys, you know,
hypothetically if somebody sued you, oh well, I would never do
anything like this. Well, hypothetically, if you did, well, I
would never do anything like that. Well, hypothetically, let's
say that you didn't have breakfast this morning. How would you
feel? Well, I But I did have breakfast this morning.
>> watch me watch it so we can deprive Tim Pool of View.
That's just idiotic. Like, they made themselves so vulnerable
by >> whether you would whe whether whether you would or
not. It's a hypothetical. Why are you fighting? >> You
could just as easily get swept up by the sort of lawsuit by a
creator if they really wanted to. Loner. Yeah, I know. Like,
the difference is though is I don't use chemical weapons. like
I don't I don't resort to lying about people or uh even like
>> okay what makes you less vulnerable to this you understand
that the the lying doesn't make you less vulnerable to it and
that's the problem is basically once this is normalized it could
just always >> even the fact in terms of what like what
harassment ever comes from my audience towards other people my
audience are a bunch of >> again also
totally subjective standard right we're going to put this totally
subjective standard here
where
if you feel like somebody is bad, I feel you're like you're bad.
I can't establish a solid line. Or maybe he's saying the solid
line is you have to lie about people. Okay. So then I want to
hear what lie Caseyron did,
right? What lie did Casey Trron do
in terms of what like what harassment ever comes from my audience
towards other people? My audience are a bunch of knitted scars.
Like there's literally nothing. the worst thing that anyone can
do to me is prove me wrong about something and then my audience
will feel embarrassed and be on my for it as well. So yeah, obviously
I'm going to feel like there's a slight a more uh more like a
more of an injustice if someone comes after me. If I'm like say
if I'm reacting to Pool and on him, yeah, he could probably copyright
me for that. Even if I don't say it's Marker Blazment, even if
I react even if I react meaning Oh, but Pisco thinks they haven't
lied or be malicious about Ethan rather than rather they just
have a difference of opinion or a misunderstanding of his positions.
I have never seen Pisco say this and I feel like I've seen him
talk on this topic a lot. So,
would this just be a lie? Sure. Get Sure. It would get uh cleared
up on stream pretty quickly. I believe it
even if I pause every two seconds. That could happen easily,
right? I can do that. Um and I would feel quite about him suing
me and I think it's a bit different to it coming to like someone
like Caseyron and you know it's different as well. You lying
like you know it's different. You're just like trying to hold
me to the exact same standard as people who are
like you're just doing the thing again where it's like you have
to hold me to the same standard as people who break every single
like social norm when it comes to engaging in the space. So no
I just I don't take it that seriously. Sorry. Yeah. I'd feel
upset if sued me and I' lonerbox does not act in ways that make
someone like Casey Tron deserving. Okay. give me the codified
rules for how you can act and then if you break those rules you
can be sued and do them such that denims Frogan and Caseyron
are all liable in the same way and you also excavate totally
xQc and asminold spoiler alert can't be done spoiler alert doesn't
exist spoiler alert completely [__] idea >> be
in big trouble and all that but it's like the end of the day
like we all know when we react to things that we are liable to
get attacked for that. We know that like what we're doing can
result in
>> well it's just subjective unless they come up with rules
to enforce it and then you have to understand that you should
have to enforce them uniformly right and to make Ian or to make
Ethan not a lying spineless
piece of it also has to include these rules would have been codified
in his head before he decided to file for the copyright thing
before he decided to register with the Library of Congress. Okay.
Super easy. So, so, so, so super easy
coming to sue you. Um, I just don't, you know, tread in a way
that's really giving people much of a reason to do it. And that's
just the social understanding that we have. >> Oh, I also
forgot. Hold on. Actually, hold on. Didn't he say earlier that
these people were making up lies about Ethan? Oh, so like a kind
of thing that's already against the law and you could sue somebody
over like that you have a totally different avenue to sue somebody
via like that maybe
>> yeah Hutch even though again I super don't care I I
would say just yeah like regardless of whether or not you would
what is your motivation here and the motivation of Ethan I think
>> no no commentary on Hutch's dodging by the way on Hutch's
total total reticence to engage in any intellectual manner >> it
matters a little like what would you do with situation
>> if if I was dumb enough to say, "Hey guys, watch me
watch Tim Pool." Like, I don't know. I feel like I I Yeah, it's
difficult for me to >> So, no bad tactics, only bad targets.
You are a idiot. Like, you are so stupid. No bad tactics, only
bad targets. It's It's kind of like It's
>> okay, should just give us the reason. >> The problem
with no bad tactics and only bad targets.
[__] me. Hang on. I there's more there. I There's
more
There's more there.
>> The problem with no bad tactics, only bad targets is
when one group unilaterally starts breaking every like or starts
committing every social phaua that they can to deal with their
like opponents and social pha.
So I think basically what I would say here is you can commit
those same social faux paws back
or escalate like one tier above.
But what I think happened here is he says chemical weapons. I
think it's like October 7th respond by nuking Gaza. That's like
what it feels like to me. Like he went way outside of this in
a way actually. Yeah. Yeah. In a way that actually affects like
the entire commentary community that affects tons of things.
You know, you know Lonerbox, you can tell when Lonerbox knows
he doesn't have a good response because he gets really angry.
Okay, so they're committing every single social phaua.
He's trying to keep DG from going skitso. Okay,
with no prompting, right? No bad tactics, only bad targets is
when someone might come to someone like me >> No, it's
not. No, it's not. In fact, I'd say when people say no bad tactics,
only bad targets, doesn't that mean the opposite of no prompting?
I thought it was like basically that's something people say when
you're upset with somebody and you justify doing something really
bad to them because you don't like them
and then it's like you're not holding to your principles because
all you care about is whether or not your target is good. It's
a totally subjective standard, right?
He's not audience captured.
>> oh, hold on. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. How do I
I don't know, man. I want to say he's not audience captured.
I might have to hold on. I'll take that back and I'll listen
again cuz to me I'm like okay no bad tactics only bad targets
means like only with no like proddding no you know preemptive
strike from their side and I'm like bro at least when I see that
on the internet it seems to mean
uh I can do something that's against my principles to you and
I can justify it by saying you're a bad person and that's pretty
much what people are arguing here. So, it's weird that he picked
the exact wording of like the thing I feel like it is and then
said it's not that. So, now I need to listen again because I
just need to I need to listen. I'm going to minimize the chat.
I don't even want to see the >> The problem with no bad
tactics, only bad targets is when one group unilaterally starts
breaking every like or starts committing every social phaua that
they can to deal with their like opponents and then
with no [__] prompting, right? No bad >> Oh,
as in Ethan didn't do anything. Um,
no. I don't think that's true.
I don't think that's true. I think Ethan was going back and forth.
I think Ethan established a back and forth dynamic with these
people. I'd say right off the bat, not unlike not unlike the
Palestinians. Okay. Ethan was like the Palestinians right off
the bat, as in he had a sincere grievance. I think people went
like sicko on Ethan over very little. I think Ethan was pretty
pretty like moldable at that time. He was still fairly pro Palestine.
I don't think right off the bat that he was this massive Zionist
that was like, you know, I actually I'm totally fine with all
these Palestinians dying. I don't think so. I think he has like
an original grievance that's very understandable and very real
and then he started engaging in tactics that basically make that
original grievance moot. Okay.
So,
so, but the idea that there's no prompting from Ethan's side,
I did misunderstand slightly. He's saying there's no prompting
from Ethan's side to make them act bad back to him, to make them
like say mean things about him, which by the way, that is ultimately
what it is, saying mean things. That's what most of these people
can be held responsible for is saying mean things. >> Only
bad targets is when someone might come to someone like me and
think, well, you know, Lord Box, he doesn't really do personal
attacks. He doesn't really do lying. He doesn't do any um like
defamation or underhanded tactics against people, but we're just
going to use it against him because of his ideology. You know,
he's like a valable he's a valid target, any means necessary,
whatever the [__] Um but if I start
Yeah. But I think
Okay. I think the tactic is bad of suing somebody,
that he picked a target for the tactic based on them being bad,
not based on why he would normally apply that tactic.
Is that confusing to anybody? I think that's pretty clear, right?
that he chose a tactic based on a bad target
that is normally considered a bad tactic and then he had to explain
to everybody why it wasn't a bad tactic in that case. Why it
was like actually this is totally justified and the entirety
of the justification
is wrong. It's lying.
Yes. So his entire his entire reasoning for using this tactic
is wrong. So, he came up with a reasoning for using the tactic
that could be good, but it is wrong and it's not what he decided.
It's not the reasoning he had when he decided to employ the tactic.
It's like basically he had decided to nuke Gaza and then somehow
Gaza got like a suitcase nuke and set it off in Tel Aviv and
now he can nuke Gaza.
But it's not no.
They set off one bomber in Tel Aviv and now they can nuke Gaza
and they can go look there was a bomber in Tel Aviv. It's really
bad. It's more like that because it's still very asymmetric,
right? So, they did come out and they did say something offensive,
but he was already planning to sue. Sorry, I'm I'm trying to
figure out the hypothetical that works here. He had already planned
to sue before they said that thing.
He'd already planned to sue these people specifically. So, again,
you can't even say that that was a part of his calculation to
decide to sue these people. Okay. All right. are responding to
someone with underhanded tactics or things that like like for
example redistricting, right? If Gavin Newsome unilaterally did,
>> oh, don't do redistricting. Oh, you don't want to do
that. Oh, you don't want to do that one.
Oh, you don't want to do that one.
Cuz that one is one that we all agree on. That's going to totally
support my side. Oh, don't do that one. When when when Gavin
Newsome decided that he was going to do something underhanded
and he went precisely to the same level Republicans did, I supported
that. Oh, sure. Yeah. If if basically Ethan thought he was being
lied about and he did some lies back, he did some like clever,
you know, I'm going to make some [__] up about these
people back. Yeah. Nobody's here arguing. Everybody's like, "Okay."
Right. Oh, like when he when he saw people gerrymandering and
he decided to gerrymander that was yeah totally justified under
every single person's like
mo everybody everybody understands that everybody gets it everybody's
cool with it. Oh
man, >> redistricting when the Republicans were playing
fair and not going against the Constitution and not reinterpreting
every single law against every president in American history
to get their way, then everyone would say, "What are you doing?
That's no bad tactics, only bad targets. What the [__]
What's the why are you doing this? You literally made it an independent
body for taking back when it's like not a totally unreasonable
escalation." Exactly.
unilaterally, but obviously if he's doing it in response to Republicans
doing it, that's different. Whereas you would go to Gavin Newsome,
like you understand this is the person you are, right? You would
go to Gavin Newsome and say, "Uh, so no bad tactics, only bad
targets. Why do you rise above it, man?" Like, yeah, you just
want people to get I don't know, you're [laughter] just
I'm I'm the person who didn't like the like the out of her apology.
Okay. Like Caseyron is the one who is actually here, right? She's
the one who was forced to make a statement essentially against
her will.
We're the people who like people doing things with uh like saying
what they mean. >> You would go >> I'm the one who
doesn't like compelled speech. You know >> what's new and
say so no bad tactics only bad targets. Why do you rise above
it man? Like >> yeah you just want people to get I don't
know you're just [__] me >> in the hypothetical
because I wouldn't do something that dumb. Okay. >> Okay
then let's if it's so difficult to hypothetical. Let me change
one last thing and I know we have a time limit here. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Suppose that it were the case that Ethan said, "I'm
suing these people." >> I will say, man, like
just all of these examples were bad. They're really bad.
I think if you I said this before also, I even said
I think I said, and this seems totally fine to me. If all that
Ethan had done was sue these people for damages plus legal fees,
I'd be like fine with that. It's like whatever. if he'd gone
into it just based on damages, right? But the thing is he registered
these copyrights so that he could go for statutory damages to
inflict actual financial ruination on these people, which is
a scale that nobody's a nobody else's actions, not even the CPS
call shockingly
like rose to that level of like I I now have a way to actually
destroy your life.
>> It's not close, right?
That's the issue is is this guy He used the nuke on no on not
even close to the right level of provocation >> because
I want them to financially suffer and I want to ruin them financially
and that was the motivation. Would you give a [__]
>> I mean it's not something that I would do personally.
>> Well, no. Okay, but >> Oh my god. Please Lunder
Box. Lon Box is watching the content enough to go like Hutch
is being just the weasleyest the most weasly here, right? Like
no matter what you believe, you could be totally on H3's side
in this, right? all the way on H3's side
and you would go, "Hutch, the are you doing here? Hutch, the
[__] is happening here? Hutch,
you're drowning. Hutch, Hutch,
wake up, Hutch, [laughter] Hutch, you're spiraling. Hutch, you're
having a mental breakdown. Hutch, wake up. Wake up. Hutch, wake
up. [laughter] >> Would you think it's a good or bad?"
>> I'm not asking whether you would personally do it. I'm
asking whether you think it's good or bad. >> I don't know
how to apply labels to these kinds of things. >> Okay.
Now that now I kind of judge something. A very easy like moral
question. Uh do you think it's okay to sue people because you
want to financially ruin them?
[laughter] I don't know. It really depends on
Uh you should say yes.
If somebody steals my patent, if I come up with a unique idea
and somebody steals that idea and makes a ton of money and like
in order to recover my losses, I have to financially ruin them.
Just say yeah. >> Circumstances, right? Like >> but
he's like literally not even thinking about it. Just like >> what
is >> in this circumstance?
You think it's okay if if his goal was only to financially ruin
these people? How about just do this circumstance? If his goal
is only to financially ruin these people, he's not trying to
protect copyright. There's nothing else here. Is this okay?
A lot of people who are I think super mind raped will still say
yes. I don't really think so, but a lot of people just say yes.
That's a pretty easy out on this conversation. Now then you have
to then you have to answer well then why did Ethan lie here the
whole time? That's very interesting do to me.
Is there a Ethan Klein sniper pointing at your forehead right
now? >> Dude Soy Bill like I feel like Soyel based on his
connections would probably just take Ethan's side. Okay. I hate
to paint him with that brush but I've seen very little in the
way of like unique thought process there. It's I'm I'm not saying
there's nothing. I'm just saying I'm I'm literally being like
the political influencer version of racist right now. I've seen
like two clips. They've been whatever. Okay. I just It's whatever.
But yeah, he's
even he can tell that Hutch is like totally full of right now.
Hutch is like not remotely
>> I'll [laughter] say it. Yes. It depends. I think uh
you know
what happened, but >> Okay, but this is what I mean, Missy.
When I say does he have a unique thought process, I don't mean
does he actually like he's a human being. Of course, he's got
something going on cognitively, but I mean does he share it?
Yes, >> no war. Stop comparing this to a [__]
war. Well, the point of them not being the same is the point
of a comparison. It's an analogy. Like, use your >> whatly
wrong to someone to try to find. >> I really don't like
that everybody's example of asymmetrical conflict is Israel and
Palestine because it makes Israel look really bad. >> All right,
can we can we pause for a second? Is it is it not possible that
Ethan Ethan was motivated by >> Oh, you see glimmers of
it more than most DJers. I don't think I'd call him a DJer.
[laughter] >> Listen, a DJ would never embarrass Destiny
in public like he did >> by [laughter] two things. That
he has been consistently pushing against what he would call like
malicious react content where you basically just do no effort,
don't do any kind of reaction, and basically just steal content
that he could be motivated by both that and personal grievance.
>> Why does your audience hate Pisco so much? Um, probably
because a lot of them are Ethan fans. Like, yeah, because >> Oh,
that's funny. Why does Why would your audience hate Pisco? What
did Pisco do to be hated? Is Is it really that
You know what Pisco did to be hated, right? You guys all know
exactly what Pisco did to be hated. Pisco's message regarding
Hutch and Loner Box. This is going to be totally clipped out
of context to make piss tomorrow. Hutch laner box tanker H3 lawsuit
denims Hassan [__]
I condemn it all. See you tomorrow. Hutch loner box tanker H3
lawsuit denims Hassan [__]
I condemn it all.
Wow. Uh Hutch and Pim are going to argue tomorrow. I think it's
going to be good. You had a podcast with Aaron? Yeah. Well, have
you considered that Aaron's a [__] Have you thought
about that, Missy? Have you like put that in your pipe and smoke
it before? You consider that Aaron's like a [__]
I don't know if you thought about that, but that's true. Where
were we here? We're still watching this. >> Besides co
as well, we try to keep them in line every now and then, but
you shouldn't hate Beast. What the [__] >> You
You ask is it possible? And I understand is it possible question.
I mean, is it logically possible? Which I mean, does it entail
a contradiction? >> Does it look plausible to you that
it could be both? >> No, it doesn't. >> I have to
watch these three go for Hutch for the entire year. Maybe, I
don't know, just quick thought, maybe Hutch shouldn't take totally
[__] positions that he can't possibly defend.
Although, I do get the sense. I hope Pisco understands that Hutch
is going to have the power of like a thousand
going through coursing through his veins tomorrow. Okay, there'll
be so many people in his DMs giving him like the best arguments
he could possibly make. So, realistically, Hutch is going to
be the ultimate golem on this. All right. Going to be so many
people DMing him with like, oh, they'll have because Hudge is
the perfect combination of he's got the opportunities and he's
got no capability of doing it. Like he's got no capacity for
actually succeeding and so everybody will be messaging him, right?
Like he's no capacity to succeed and he's got all the capability,
all of sorry, all the opportunity.
So it's just like everybody's going to be like, "Hutch, please
say this and nothing else. Hutch, please say this. Hutch, please
say this. Hutch, could you please say this? Thank you, Hutch.
Thank >> It does it does it does not look plausible to
me. It does not look plausible to me at all time.
I'm going to refresh if I can I can >> Okay, cool. >> Well,
I'm going to refresh my things.
>> Okay. Gotcha. Uh based on that 10-minute conversation,
right, who won the Ethan Klein dramas debate? Not enough time
passed for a winner to be declared in my >> You might have
no idea what I don't know the merits of either side. I have no
>> Okay. Well, >> all I know is Casey Tron was horrifically
embarrassed. Uh, doesn't matter if she believed what she read
or not. The fact that she had to read it was just
>> tragic to watch. It was It was pretty >> IRI knows
exactly what's going on and he just wants to laugh at Casey Tron.
>> Sad. I don't know if anything was >> I I promise
you I knows like exactly. He He knows he takes Ethan's side and
he was just like I love watching that rant. Read that [__]
Let's go >> that. But I mean, you can't with these big
boys who have money. Like this is kind of like America in a nutshell.
If you got money, you can bring almost anyone to their knees,
man. >> Yeah, there there's that excellent John Oliver
segment on slap suits where it's like they're just using it to
silence people. It's it's okay. So surely somebody here will
go, "No, but that's not what Ethan's doing, right? There's a
really good John Oliver segment on
there's a really good John Oliver segment on slapsuits.
Isn't that what this is, guys?"
I feel like both Lerbox and Hutch should go, "Wait, that's not
what this is, though. That's not what this is." >> Because
I can afford litigation and lawyers, I'm going to make your life
a living hell regardless of whether or not I'm justified in doing
so. And I I think that's potentially a bad thing. We should do
something about it. I have no idea what the cloud circumstances
are. Honestly, don't care. >> But these Casey, Tron, and
them needed to be smarter about how they went after him and >> they
failed miserably, so they >> I don't think they did. I
think Denims was plenty smart about it.
He was like obviously plenty smart about it. Um, I I still literally
don't know about Froen. I will never care about Froggen,
Um, unless she does a hostage unless she does like a beheading
video, too. If she does a beheading video, too, then I'll actually
ask people about Frogan,
but until I see it, I'm not really going to care that much. >> They
can't really cry foul. >> The thing is people can give
me that. Like, if you want to make the argument for even for
denims or even Froggen, like you could probably
I could probably quite easily convinced of that. Even for Denim's
case, like especially I I don't think I ever thought denim.
>> Okay. Has Lonerbox put like statements on the record
that support Denims and say it was wrong for Ethan to sue her?
Or is he just saying like
Cuz maybe maybe it's possible that Lonerbox just hasn't looked
into this at all and he like hasn't made that opinion known cuz
I feel like I would have heard about it, right?
If
if he was like out here going like, "Oh, you shouldn't sue Denims.
That's really [__] up."
I feel like I would have heard about it, but I didn't hear about
it. was like one who deserved like getting sued in the same way.
You realize that Caseyron is above and beyond when it comes to
React stuff, right? Like morally we like there's no one who is
moral frogging about the Caseyron who who ser sincerely believes
even when I was playing Warcraft and
>> if he's going to say that she barely uses things now
videos on in the background and not pausing that often even that
was like way above and beyond anything Casey Trump was doing.
She just literally she just leaves videos on and leaves a loop
of herself on the corner when she's not >> What was uh
what was Spider supposed to come back and discuss
and whenever you say too lazy to some like this Spider just so
you know it's just because you ran obviously >> there dude
what are you talking about then Ethan should sue XQC
welcome to >> that's not even that's not even remotely
the argument.
Um, he should sue XQC because XQC was his original dragon. And
XQC literally big dipped him. Just [__] him down
super hard and was like, you know, Ethan, all of the stuff you
you blame me for, all the stuff you got mad at me about, I'm
going to do all of those things to you, Ethan. I'm going to do
all of them. I'm going to take your thumbnail. I'm going to take
your title. I'm not even going to react. I'm I'm literally going
to going to pause and I'm going to say, "Guys, I'm not talking
cuz I'm just learning. And then I'm going to unpause and watch
and watch you see because you know that your entire lawsuit rests
on you not offending the parts of my audience that would criticize
you. Good luck. Good luck. XQC started the mental decline. XQC
just owns this guy. XQC got in his head with the worm and it
never went away. XQC got in his head with the worm, wormed into
his brain and made him love watches. What a cringe hobby. What
a what an utterly cringe hobby. Civil law, idiot. Civil law is
you sue who you want to sue. You sue who you want to. Ethan is
not the American
law is not the American legal system. If you think that everyone
should get sued or no one gets sued, then make it a criminal
thing. Campaign to make copyright a criminal case rather than
civil.
>> Civil lawsuits are always going to be based on whether
or not someone wants to sue someone. You understand that, right?
But like you understand that just suing somebody talk about you
for copyright with that exact motivation in mind that's like
obviously bad and everybody should be calling that out and instead
we're getting a whole bunch of people supporting Ethan because
they really hate Caseyron.
That's like the big problem. That's like the obvious problem
here, right?
I mean come on Soy Pill. This is so obviously not a slap suit.
Um it's definitely a slap suit. Like hold on. I need to see the
What is it? Slap. What does slap mean? strategic lawsuit against
public participation. Oh no, it's exactly a slapsuit. Like precisely
and entirely and exactly a slapsuit. Yeah, 100%.
Right. That seems really obvious because again, he obviously
formed the intent to sue these people before any of their
What did he form that intent based on? If he if he couldn't have
possibly formed it off of them saying they were maliciously stealing
views, then what did he form it off of? It's obvious because
they all only fit into one collective group and it's the people
who are what is public participation. So it is a strategic lawsuit
against public participation. Yes. Obviously yes. Thank
>> Yeah. I mean like Hutch said they literally said I'm
going to do the illegal thing like on a live stream. So it's
like all right. Like it's >> Oh, they just now Pisco's
gone so he doesn't get to come back and point out the obvious
thing. >> Not even that's not even the worst thing for
me. Like the worst thing for the dog pile like like I don't know
guy if you're aware that that CPS got called on on Ethan's like
you guys you guys hear about this. >> Has anybody heard
I don't know if you heard about this but do you know that like
CPS was called?
Guys,
I don't know if you heard about this but CPS was literally called
I'm I'm sorry. I'm going to keep calling it the skull cost. Okay.
I I fully
I fully acknowledge and respect and and truly
abhore the Holocaust, okay? But I fully deny will always stand
on business denying the Skulla. Okay? The Skulla is not real.
It is a hallucination. It is political propaganda. It never happened.
It doesn't I don't care. I
actually That's not even my point. Usually when I say this, I'm
tired. It's usually that it did happen, but I don't care. I It
Yeah, sure. Sure. He got sent some skulls. I literally don't
care anymore. I don't care. You don't get to go and upend all
of, you know, fair use in the commentary space because you got
sent some skulls.
Sorry, man. Sorry. Sorry. Much terrified Ethan will send skulls
to his house >> Kids and like a government. >> I
I do like the conspiracy theory that it was Ethan sending skulls
to himself. Okay. It's very funny.
>> I don't know if I believe it.
>> Showed up to his home and um like I'm not Yeah, go ahead.
Well, like you can't control everybody in your audience doing
crazy, right? >> No, I'm and I'm not. To be clear, I'm
not encouraged by the creators. >> It's just more evidence
there's motivation to spite than you're admitting it. You're
so clever.
You're so clever. I don't know why. Like, did you just did you
just have [__] >> Hold on, hold on, hold on,
hold on. >> Yeah, go ahead. >> Well, like you can't
control everybody in your audience doing crazy, right? >> No,
I'm And I'm not to be cleared by the >> It's just more
evidence there's motivation is spite than you're admitting it.
You're so clever.
You're so clever. I don't know why. Like did you just did you
just have goo in your ears for the last 8 billion times where
I said that Ethan was doing this to Caseyron and those people
specifically because of the harassment because of those communities.
Yeah. Of course he is. That's how civil tell me.
Yeah. So he's like totally reaching out
So he's totally attempting
to collectively punish this group, right?
He is hitting the people he can because he wants to punish that
group broadly. and you guys support that, which like isn't surprising
given everything else, but it's like a little surprising to just
put it on the record. >> How are civil suits not how do
they not imply
how do they not imply some degree of spite? How you have to make
the choice to sue someone? You can have 10 people you in a way
that is civily liable or whatever and it's your choice which
ones you sue. Obviously, say if one of them is nice.
>> Yeah. But again, it's a total social phauxa to go after
somebody for this when they've clearly done like a fair use usage
of your work.
And he's in a space where talk, the thing that he's really asked
Matt about is totally welcome. He engages in it all the time.
He literally settled a defamation case as the loser of that case,
the clear loser of that case where he had to issue a public apology
just like he made Casey Tron do. Like he's very he's very much
in these spaces lying about people all the time. his his whole
this hand ringing from Ethan's side about how lying is so evil.
Holy Why do you support Ethan Klein then? Excuse me. You support
the guy who li I Let's put it on Let's put it to a vote. Who
the [__] Sorry, not a vote. Let's just put it on
the record. Ethan Klein's lied way more than Casey Tron, right?
Although, actually, I don't know how far back. Maybe not. Casey
Tron's gone back a long ways. I'm only aware of her stuff with
regards to Ethan. Ethan Klein has lied about Creators Online
way more than Casey Tron's lied about him. That's not a fair.
Can we do denims? [__] I I just realized Casey Tron's
career goes back so many years I'm unaware of. She's almost certainly
lied a lot back then in this situation. Sure. But even I'm just
thinking like Ethan Klein has a lot of situations where he lies.
Dude, look at the entire Gokanaru video. Oh, wait. Can I even
pull it up or is it like gone? My response to Ethan Klein. No,
this is just his response, right? Somebody's got the the actual
Gokanaru video somewhere. There's a whole video about how much
he lies. Just how much he lies. Like he's not a good person.
He's never been a good person. >> Nicer to you or is um
like maybe going to be have more resources and you don't want
to go for them or they just haven't given you much of a reason
to be upset with them. Of course, you're going to sue the other
ones who are just being flagrant. It's all
>> Wait, no, no, no, no, no. That's not what hap that's
not what's happening here, though. Um, basically under the normal
law that everybody would accept this under, right? Um, you sue
for damages. There are no damages here. The people who he could
sue for damages who he could really make an argument damaged
him in some way tangibly,
he doesn't sue. He sues people he has a totally separate grievance
against.
And Wendy said, "Look up the collateral purpose thing." Maybe,
maybe, maybe. Uh, I didn't realize how much he lied about Panata.
I thought the that the looking to off tweet was real.
Oh,
didn't Eerite do that, too? Wasn't that what Eerite? Erodite
leaned into calling him a as well, didn't she? Oh, weird, weird,
weird, weird, weird, weird, weird. This is against the spirit
of both defamation laws and copyright laws. Wow. Remember the
video with the edited chat for denims? Pretty bad. Okay. All
right. Well,
that's probably it for today. W stream. Okay. All right. W stream.
Cool. I might chill in the Discord for a little bit after this.
I don't know what I'm doing. I I'm might chill in the Discord.
I might listen to my audiobook. Wait, hold on. I just Why did
I say I'm ending? There's way more to the There's way more to
the video. I'm sorry, guys. I actually am falling asleep. That's
my >> It's a human choice. That's why That's why we have
civil law. >> To be clear, I'm not accusing. >> I
don't know why it's I just like paused and I'm like, "Well, that's
it. That's it. I guess we're done, guys. Bye. My bad." those
creators of like orchestrating that. I do think that Denims was
like wildly irresponsible. There's one >> Hello Spider.
>> Yo, what up
some dumb [__] on YouTube? >> I'll do the whole
uh yo lord box. Uh I don't do that [__] You do that
[__]
>> But anyway, so like what's your thoughts on like >> Spider
be real. Is is English like your eighth language or Come on,
man.
Come on, man.
I think this is just coded racism when people say like what I
just did to you. Okay, don't don't let them fool you, Spider.
Okay, it's just coded racism. Don't let them tell you it's not
because you're black. It is because you're black. Like every
time it's [__] like doing the whole like doing the
whole like moral grand standing on this [__] >> Um
I think it's a bit weird to think like the problem is you want
to come and have the argument. >> Ethan said two things
basically. Um as far as Well, he said one thing and what the
other thing is obvious. He said that he wanted to go for people
who didn't express a malicious intent because to him which is
an arbitrary standard. It's not the legal standard but his personal
standard for choosing to take the civil suit forward was because
they stated a malicious intent. And I think that is okay to do
like it's as far as you want to set like some kind of >> nope.
Nope. Nope. Obvious lie. Obvious lie. Decided to sue them. He
decided he was going to try to sue people before that even happened.
>> A social standard or a social precedent in the streamer
space that makes sense. I think it's it's it's probably okay
to do that. Like it
it's not going to be legal. It's not it's not going to be the
legal precedent, but for socially like I think it's fair. Uh
you would have to to believe this in terms of his reasoning pursuing
people. You would have to believe that he registered these videos
and went, "Well, I'm going to sue them if and only if they maliciously
state their attempt their their intention to steal my
but if they don't, then I'll I'll just totally let all of this
go, guys. And if you believe that, I don't know what to tell
you, okay? I don't I literally don't know." But obviously when
he's saying that it's going to protect other streamers from Disney
or whoever else who come in with copyright suits um because it
sets a precedent of malice having to be the intent what the
what makes you liable. That's not true. That's not going to change
the law. Like regardless of whether Ethan tries to set a precedent
of malice or not, it's not going to change the fact that if you
have something registered and you copyright it, then it's protected
by copyright uh in terms of liabil strict liabilities. and if
you do it, it doesn't matter what your intent is. So, he's wrong
when he's saying that. But it could still be true that that's
his his own personal like or a social standard that he wants
to set. So, it's just I don't know why you would get so and also
the second argument to say that these are mutually exclusive
that you're going after intent, but it's also because you don't
like these people. Why can't it be both? Why can't it be that
you don't like these people, you want to sue them, but you also
don't want to do it in a way that looks that basically um sets
a social precedent that everyone could just sue anyone. >> Yeah.
I mean, there's written like DMCA uh DMCA
uh YouTube like for a while. So, I don't know why like people
are like mad about this. Um
but the situation
kind of weird. Oh, also yeah, he didn't even take >> he
[clears throat] didn't take the step of DMCA here as people normally
would, right?
So, he did all his pre-work.
He was aware of the people he wanted to go after. He could have
easily said, "Okay, I'm going to try to DMC them on Twitch, right?"
No. >> Do you think um
do you think it's possible for like
This is literally the social precedent he set here by the way
was XUC just gets to steal the whole thing without reacting barely
at all and it's fine. >> Inclined to go after like Hassan
probably or what? >> Um probably not because again that
would be he probably could legally but morally um but that would
obviously undermine his standard because Hassan didn't express
a malicious intent and Hassan was actually asked to watch the
video and he reacted for like 9 hours. So that would be
>> Yeah. No, it's not the malicious intent thing at all.
>> Yeah. Big overstep if he did it with Han regardless
of how much Hassan can defend himself legally.
>> Interesting. Interesting. Interesting. I don't know.
I feel like I don't know. I think Pisco I think feel like I feel
like Pisco
he's kind of goofy. Okay. I can't I'll go [__] Okay.
I feel like he >> I don't really give a [__]
I just say things I don't really give a [__] I don't
really give a [__] I want to actually have to everything
I say cuz I don't really give a [__] Okay. made Casey
Trump poor. Okay. He would he should have went harder on a
I don't know why Pisco is doing the whole moral grand standing
of like, oh, it's not moral. Oh, he's doing
Sherlock, come on. It's like cringe. Like, stop. >> Wait.
Oh, no. It's not moral. No, Sherlock. It's cringe. Kind of.
Does Spider understand that the entirety of all of his income
is currently predicated on people who argue about what moral
standards should be doing clips for Loner Box and are relevant?
That's what his entire is based on, right? I don't care. I So
what if it's a moral? I'm going to cry. It's a moral.
>> Yeah,
that's like what the whole space is. I don't know. >> It's
weird. Cringe. I don't know. It's kind of weird. Got to roll
a little, >> Okay. Well,
>> take care. >> All right. Well, I don't know. So,
I'm
particular stream where she was sort of like implying that it
was justified and this sort of thing. But like the the the massive
dog pile that that space like all the creators in the Hassan
orbit did with Ethan and Ela was like one of the most disgusting
things that I've seen in all my years on the internet. >> I
think Denims has turned out to be a real dumb with some of the
things she said. Uh she was praising Osama bin Laden's uh >> manifesto
on her stream and then hearing that she's praising CPS getting
called on somebody is ridiculous. So she just sounds like a real
dumb [__] All right, you heard it here, folks. We
are pro Denims is dumb on live and learn. I'm happy we got to
>> Well, it just shows you that not the the smartest people
don't always rise to the top. In fact, some of the most mentally
unwell people tend to become the biggest streamers out there.
You you kind of have to be a bit mentally unwell to become a
giant streamer. >> I was going to say while we're stirring
the pot, I always wonder who's watching Azimon Gold. Why is he
so big? So, >> it's probably just a lot of young guys.
I would assume I I would
>> actually just precisely wrong. I believe I believe Asmin
Gold's like literally average age is like 29 28. Asen Gold's
got like nothing but old guys watching him. It's the stream.
Okay.
Yeah. It's like it's like the precisely the opposite. >> As
soon as Target demo is like 25 and >> Yeah. I was
Dude, how did he how does he just do that? How does he do that?
So wrong. Spider, just hop on the stream, bro. Just hop on the
stream right now. Hop on the stream. You always come here and
then he's going to be like, "No, man. I'm just I'm No, man. It's
really stupid. I'm just going to go to sleep.
How about you hop on the stream,
Waiting, waiting, waiting. I'm too tired to even know what's
going on. So, you got a real shot here. Will you be nice? Yeah,
I'll be nice. Don't do this Scooby-Doo voice [laughter] call.
It's not a racist impression. It's an honest impression. I don't
even know that he's black. Okay, I do know that he's black, but
it's not like a black person voice. It's not like he's a black
American. He's like from somewhere else. He's from some swathoid
country. Okay. I bet all of the all the people there sound like
this when they speak English. Wait, he's not American, is he?
>> He can't be American. Stop. It's not. It was not me
being Shut up. Absolutely not me being racist. You guys are full
of Spider. Welcome to the stream. Please tell everybody that
my accent was not racist. Thank you. >> So, have a So,
like, what's your So, is your main problem with Ethan like the
way he did it or like or I'm confused.
>> Sorry. Did you not hear me doing an impersonation or
an impression? You just confirmed for the stream that that was
not racist real quick. >> Yeah, it was racist. I I also
I don't know what you did, but I don't really give a [__]
>> Perfect. Boom. Absolved. >> Absolved. So, wait,
what was your
>> My question was like, is your main problem with Ethan?
Is it the way he's going about it or is it the so-called him
defending the reaction content? >> Those are the same thing.
Okay. The
>> way he's going about it is by lying about his intentions.
>> You think >> he's doing something that normally
you would get blown the up for by everybody around him. >> He
would normally get mocked to high heaven. He get tred and feathered
for it. So he had to come up with a justification. That justification
is a >> Yeah. I think I think the average person probably
agrees that like what Ethan's going at it is like probably malicious,
>> Yeah. If he was doing it to anybody but universally
reviled people who had run like who had like a massive PR campaign
run against them for like two years straight, he's doing it against
anybody else, he would get [__] and feathered off
the internet. >> For sure.
>> Yeah. And I think basically that PR campaign has been
used to blow up these people's actions in a way that is like
not commensurate with reality
Like while they are gross in their actions maybe in some cases,
uh I don't know. So maybe you can help me. What did Casey Trron
do? >> I'm not really sure what case I mean I spoke to
Veem and I think I said in DMs like I'm not really sure what
Casey Trron did specifically. Um I think I told like just really
quick I just have to add something now. So you say I'm not sure
what she did but Lonerbox's entire justification was these people
are doing like chemical weapons. >> I'm not sure what he
means but uh probably just like
>> um not reacting to the content. I don't know. I'm not
sure. No, no, because I think we've all agreed that the reaction
had nothing to do with the if the reaction had anything to do
with suing people, then XQC be probably getting sued, right?
>> Like it's not it's not about and Denims wouldn't be
getting sued. So, it's not really about the reaction. >> Yeah.
It's probably the whole
Ethan it's probably the whole like Hassan Ethan. I think we probably
agree, right? >> Yeah. So, basically like I think what
you have to do here is just say like collective punishment is
justified. If that's your position, collective punishment is
justified. Then W I guess >> like Alice White fight >> that
has to be your position. That's like that is everyone's position
who's like against
who's like who's like defending Ethan on suing this these
>> It's just that collective punishment is >> Would
that matter in like a like a law sense or something or
>> No, no, it's just like a moral position, right? Oh,
sorry. Actually, it does matter in a law sense at least in under
international law. If you're like Israel collectively punishing
Gazins, yes, it does matter. Sorry. >> I'm trying to like
just like >> look for like in this case like >> just
in a moral sense like you think it's justified like when Trump
said we need to torture the families of terrorists to get them
to like give us information. You believe that's morally not really
that bad, right? >> Pretty bad. >> Oh, but what the
whole is bad? >> Yeah. Why is that bad? >> It's pretty
bad. Pretty bad. What can I >> What if they were like vaguely
related? What if like the woman What if the wife did like taxes
for >> Oh, you're talking about You're talking about like
You're talking about like if the Okay. You're talking about if
like
>> you talking about that quote that like Donald Trump
the like terrorist. >> Yeah, we should like we should like
bomb their families, we should like totally collectively punish
these people. Now, like is Casey Tron innocent? I'm sure she
said mean things about Ethan, but one I would say probably the
mean thing she said if they were lies, there's a way to go after
her for that legally.
Not this. There's an actual way to go after her legally, right?
Yeah,
>> Oh yeah, defamation. You could do that.
>> otherwise it's just talking on the internet, which Ethan
should be able to handle and do back.
Or if you have some proof that she did the CPS call, maybe then
we can have that conversation. But in my opinion, trying to say,
well, I don't know if you know this, but their side called CPS
on Ethan and then justifying this based on that is totally insane
to me.
And I'm not saying that their side is good or morally justified
to do these things to Ethan. I don't think so. I'm saying that
punishing Casey Tron uniquely or that side based on you you just
want to punish anybody on that side you can and this is a person
you found,
right? You're not sure that they really engaged in anywhere near
that level of tactic, but you're going to string them up anyway.
I think that's stupid. I think that's wrong. Didn't Denims like
said on stream that like, "Hey, just watch my [__]
instead of watching this content or some [__] or
>> um I think she read a chat and said I was going to stream
it." So before she watched it, she read a chat and said, "Yeah,
I'm going to stream it." They were like, "Hey, are you going
to watch this here? I don't want to watch that other thing."
She was like, "I'm going to stream it." Yeah. >> Unless
you're talking about after. But how could how could what she
says after be the predicate like her setting up to siphon views
if she only does it after the fact. She can no longer siphon
views after the fact. She says if you enjoyed not giving that
view video any views, leave a like. Obviously, that's not going
to affect whether or not people watch it with her. Right. >> Right.
But like I'm kind of my question is like okay, so like what
cuz like Ethan pretty much won, right, with the whole Casey True.
>> Yeah. Casey Tron's got a way different reaction.
I'm not saying, by the way, I'm not saying Ethan is not like
going to win the case against uh even Denims. I he would absolutely
win the case against Caseyron.
>> Yeah. I'm just saying like >> like irrelevant
to what I'm talking about right now. You can identify that.
>> If you just like if you just want a concession on that
Ethan can sue and then he can Yeah. >> I mean I could probably
just make a concession about that is like I mean Ethan can sue.
I mean this relation I mean I think first is just like petty
relationship but I don't know.
>> Yeah. And I just think probably risking like
risking a precedent that [__] over all reactions.
Risking I mean just doing something that's a total social phaua
right like not just DMCAing but actually just suing somebody
straight up and registering your copyright in a way that gets
you statutory damages and threatens financial ruination on some
of these people. I think it's totally disgusting. I think it's
beyond skulls. I think it's beyond um I I think it's even beyond
CPS for Casey Tron. >> Okay. Okay. >> You do. Would
you agree or disagree with
>> I'll probably say uh probably concede and say a little
bit. Probably probably
Yeah. I mean I guess sorry I don't want to do both sides of the
argument, but I guess the argument back would be that you didn't
think maybe people think Ethan didn't do very much before
the skulls were sent or something. I think that's what the argument
would be. >> I I mean I think I told one box on stream
like or I don't know I think like a random conversation like
why don't Ethan just like go after like bada but like I think
someone said like well he's in a different country so probably
wouldn't matter right >> no idea.
Um I don't know if you can see somebody in whatever country he's
in.
Um yeah so I just you understand why Pisco is like soying now.
Do you understand why he's saying like this is wrong? Because
it's like obviously wrong. Probably under any if you like Lunbox's
content or irrelevance content, which I know you do because you
edit for them, you would probably almost certainly have to concede
that this is >> Which just leads me to like the final point
which is
>> Yeah. The final point is just basically what you're
actually mad about is you think that whatever is done to this
Caseyron like rancid is okay. That's like your position, right?
>> Well, I'm as a I'm Well, I'm petty. I mean, I like the
drama.
I'm pretty
like I don't but I think objectively
it's pretty bad since like you're kind of like so like I don't
I don't think it's that deep, you know? Like >> it is pretty
deep. >> Like I think >> he tried to take this woman's
house like like he he threatened taking this woman's house away
to get a win on drama >> to get like an apology. >> It's
not that. It's not it's not it's not that. is that like >> even
if Katron and Denims and Frogan
like stole views from I don't know I don't know what I'm saying
like stole views from Ethan or didn't uh you know he still made
like hella money off of the Sonic right so um >> I I would
be fine with them him suing for actual damages but he's suing
for statuto damages instead I think it's garbage but >> so
uh you think he should just went for like defamations >> if
he feels like they lied but I feel like they didn't lie and That's
what actually upsets him. >> No, by Eden. Like like what
>> Oh, I probably think he doesn't have any real way to
sue these people for defamation. I think I don't think they lie
about him as much as people say they do. I think the issue people
have is
there are like maybe slightly soy but honestly like arguable
at least
like conclusions you can draw from Ethan's stories about the
being on his floor. And while I think it's stupid to draw those
conclusions and call CPS, it's probably defensible and not a
lie under the law. So I think he probably has no case in terms
of defamation.
Like I think broadly the things he's being that are being stated
about him are either factual or just arguable. And I I think
it's insane to call CPS for any reason on him. But I do think
that he just has no recourse under the law.
I think what he should do is just do content making fun of these
people
Um I guess so. Yeah.
I could have made more uh more uh money, you know. Would have
been
But like I don't know. I'm just I'm a pretty guy. What can I
say? Um
>> well I don't know. You came on here with like heat for
Pisco and I'm like well obviously Pisco's right.
I know. I know. I just It's just the whole just the whole drama.
Like I I'm a guy like morally. I don't really like give two like
about Chron like honestly. But but
>> Yeah. Exactly. So when I said that your position is
Casey Tron's a rancid and anything done to her is okay. That's
just your >> Yeah. I know. But I'm saying Yeah. Yeah. It's
like objectively [snorts] it's pretty bad for my >> I think
that's like everybody on your side just thinks she's a rancid
who deserves whatever happens to her.
Yeah, I think on my side, I think everyone agrees that it's just
petty. Like what Ethan did to K was like >> No, it's not
petty. The true belief is she's a rancid and anything that happened
to her, I would be psyched if it was bad.
That's literally what it is. That has to be what it is, right?
It's not just petty because you're saying it's morally bad. That's
not petty. Pettiness is something that's not morally bad. It's
just like something you kind of inconvenience somebody. It's
not like a moral wrong. But now you're saying, "Well, I don't
care if it's a moral wrong." In fact, it is a moral wrong, and
I think that's funny,
>> right? Or you'd have to distinguish. >> Got to
figure it out.
>> All right.
Well, thanks for coming on.
>> You see? >> Yeah. Have a good one. See you. >> You
too.
>> Bye. Pretty sure he doesn't understand what sach story
means. No, he can count to 17. He gets it. Um, could Hassan sue
Ethan for using his clips in the content
Probably. Probably not. No, I don't think so. I think the content
nuke's pretty close to what the original Matt Hos lawsuit is,
just in a very much extended way. I don't think you can get him
for it. I think probably Idubbbz could have gotten him in this
same way with the Library of Congress. I don't I don't hate Spider
even after that
Like I he he basically just said it, right? Like oh yeah, like
it's a moral wrong and I don't care.
Which is just he's a rancid hater. Anything good anything bad
that happens to her is good. Which, you know, I guess. So
if people are just honest, it's like there really is probably
no reason to argue this with most people.
That's most people's opinion when it comes down to it. This is
how they're going to function. This how they're wired. I'm shocked
that Ethan's statements of bad faith haven't [__]
him over in court. Well, has he really gone to court and litigated
this very much? I don't think he's really gone to court and litigated
it very much. We'll see if he litigates where the moral side
this Well, I think they they try to do the both sides of it where
they're like, "Yeah, the threat was bad, but like he didn't actually
take her house away." Like, yeah, but he compelled speech from
her under threat of taking her house away. It's kind of weird,
man. It's very weird. Like I said, I just do I do things that
make it hyperbolic to illustrate, but it's like I'm going to
take your house away unless you dance in a circle and call yourself
a little piggy. Say, I'm a little piggy and dance in a circle
and then I won't take your house away. You rancid what we witnessed,
right? That's what happened. So, if if you're good with stuff
like that happening, somebody who's rich can do that to somebody
who's poor, then we're all good, I guess. Anyway,
all that was fun at the end of the stream.
Little quick dip in at the end of the stream. do some fun stuff,
see what's going on. Okay, I'll end there. We'll talk to you
guys later. Okay, I think the most pathetic people are guys like
Nicholas Yoroyo, whose entire career depends on reacting to others
content, yet he defends Ethan pulling this crap.
Uh, well, yeah, that that does sound like what Queen's been arguing
for a while now. Keep spreading the good word, DNA 11. Okay,
have a good night, everybody. I'll talk to you guys later. Bye
bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye.